what to you is beautiful about
mathematics
i love
a mathematics that some people don't
even think of as mathematics which is
beautiful creative
mathematics where we look at maths in
different ways we visualize it
we think about
different solutions to problems a lot of
people think of maths as
you have one method and one answer
and what i love about maths is the
multiple different ways you can see
things
different methods different ways of
seeing different
in some cases different solutions
so that is what is beautiful to me about
mathematics that you can see and solve
it in many different ways and
also the sad part that many people think
that maths is just
one answer and one method
so to you the beautiful the beauty
emerges when you have a problem with a
solution and you start adding other
solutions
simpler solutions
weirder solutions more interesting some
that are visual some of their algebraic
geometry all that kind of stuff yeah i
mean i i always say that you can take
any maths area and make it visual
and we say to teachers give us your most
dry boring
maths and we'll make it a visual
interesting creative problem and
turns out you can do that with any area
of maths
and i think we've given
p it's been a great disservice to kids
and others that it's always been numbers
lots and lots of numbers
numbers can be great but you can think
about maths in other ways besides
numbers do you find that
most people are better visual learners
or is this just something that's
complementary
what's the kind of the full spectrum of
students in the way they like to explore
math would you say i mean there's
definitely people who come into
the classes i do who are more interested
in visual thinking and like visual
approaches but it turns out what the
neuroscience is telling us is that when
we think about maths there are two
visual pathways in the brain and
we should all be thinking about it
visually
some approaches have been to say well
you're a visual learner so we'll give
you visuals and you're
not a visual learner but
actually if you think you're not a
visual learner it's probably more
important that you have a visual
approach
so you can develop that part of your
brain so you were saying that there's
some kind of interconnected aspect to it
so the visual connects with the
non-visual yeah so this is what the
neuroscience has shown us that when you
work on a maths problem there are five
different brain pathways
and that the most
high achieving people in the world are
people who have more connections between
these pathways so if you see a maths
problem with numbers but you also see it
visually
that will cause a connection to happen
in your brain between these pathways
and if you maybe write about it with
words that would cause another
connection or maybe you build it with
something physical that would cause a
different connection
and
what we want for kids is
we call it a multi-dimensional
experience of math seeing it in
different ways experiencing it in
different ways
that will cause that great connected
brain
you know there's these stories of
physicists doing the same i find
physicists are often better at
building that part of their brain of
using visualization for intuition
building because you ultimately want to
understand
the like the deepest secret underneath
this problem and for that you have to
intuit your way there yeah and you you
mentioned offline that um one of the
ways you might approach a problem is to
try to tell a story about it
and some of it is like legend but i'm
sure it's not always is you know you
have einstein
uh thinking about a train
you know and the speed of light and you
know that kind of intuition is useful
yeah you start to like imagine
a physical world like how does
this idea manifest itself in the
physical world and then start playing in
your mind with that physical world and
think is this going to be true is this
going to be true right
einstein is well known for thinking
visually
and
people talk about how he really didn't
want to go anywhere with problems
without thinking about them visually but
the other thing you mentioned that
sparked something for me is
thinking with intuition like having
intuition about maths problems
that's another thing that's often absent
in maths class the idea that you might
think about a problem and
use your intuition
um but so important
and when mathematicians are interviewed
they will very frequently talk about the
role of intuition and solving problems
but not commonly
acknowledged or
brought into education yeah i mean
that's what it is like
if if you
task yourself with building an intuition
about a problem
that's what
that's where you start to pull in like
um
what is the pattern i'm seeing in order
to understand the pattern you might want
to then start utilizing visualization
but ultimately that's all in service of
like
solving the puzzle
like cracking it open yeah you get the
simple explanation of why
why things are the way they are
as opposed to um
like you said having a particular
algorithm that you can then execute to
solve the problem
yeah but it's hard it's hard yeah
reasoning is really hard yeah it's it's
hard i mean
i love to value what's hard in maths
instead of being afraid of it we know
that when you struggle it's actually a
really good time for your brain you want
to be struggling when you're thinking
about things so
if it's hard to think intuitively about
something that's probably a really good
time for your brain
i i used to work with somebody called
sebastian thran who
it's a great sort of mathematician you
might think of him an ai person and i
remember in one interview i did with him
he talked about how they'd built robots
i think for the smithsonian
and how they were having this trouble
with them picking up white noise
and
he said they had to solve it they had to
work out like what's going on and how he
intuitively
worked out what the problem was
but then it took him three weeks to show
it mathematically i thought that was
really interesting that how you can have
this intuition and know something works
it's kind of different from going
through that long mathematical process
of proving it
but so important yeah i think probably
our brains are evolved
as like intuition machines
and the uh the the math of like showing
it like
formally is probably an extra thing that
we're not designed for you see that with
feynman and his
i mean it's just all of these physicists
definitely you see um
starting with intuition sometimes
starting with an experiment
and then the experiment inspires
intuition but you can think of an
experiment as a kind of visualization
right just like let's
let's take whatever the heck we're
looking at and draw it
and and draw like the pattern as it
evolves as the thing grows for n equals
one for n equals two n equals three and
you start uh to play with it and then in
the modern day which i loved uh doing
is you know you can write a program that
then visualizes it for you right and
then you can start exploring it
programmatically
and that that and then uh
you can do so interactively too i i tend
to not
uh like interactive because the way it
takes to way too much work because you
have to click and move and stuff i love
to interact through writing programs
that's my particular brain software
engineer so like
you can you can uh do all these kinds of
visualizations uh and then there's the
tools of visualization like color
uh all those kinds of things yeah that
you're absolutely right they're actually
not
taught very much right like the art of
visualization not taught
and
we love as well color coding like when
you represent something mathematically
you can show color to show the growth
and kind of code that so if i have an
algebraic expression for a pattern
maybe i show the x with a certain color
but also right in that color so you can
see the
relationship
very cool and um yeah we particularly in
our work with elementary teachers
many of them come to our workshops and
they're literally in tears when they see
things making sense visually
because they've spent their whole lives
think not realizing you can really
understand things with these visuals
it's quite powerful
you say that
there's something about there's
something valuable to learning
when the thing that you're doing is
challenging it's difficult so a lot of
people say you know math is hard or math
is too hard
or too hard for me
do you think
math should be easy or should it be hard
i think it's great when
things are challenging but there's
something that that's really key to
being able to
deal with challenging maths and that is
knowing that you can do it and i think
the problem in education is a lot of
people have got this idea that you're
either born with a math sprain or you're
not
so when they start to struggle they
think oh i don't have that maths brain
and then they will literally sort of
switch off in their brain and things
will go downhill from that point
so struggle becomes a lot easier and
you're able to struggle if you don't
have that idea
but you know that you you can do it you
have to go through this struggle to get
there but you're you're able to do that
and so we're hampered in being able to
struggle with these ideas we've been
given about what we can do
ask a difficult question here yes so
there's kind of um
i don't know what the right term is but
some people
are um
struggle with learning in different ways
like their brain is
constructed in different ways
and
how much should
as educators should we make room for
that
so how do you know the difference
between this is hard and i don't like
doing hard things versus my brain is
wired in a way where i need to learn in
very different ways i can't learn it
this way how do you find that
line how do you operate in that gray
area so this is why being a teacher is
so hard and people really don't
appreciate how difficult teaching is
when you're faced with i know 30
students who think in different ways and
um
but this is also why i believe it's so
important to have this multi-dimensional
approach to maths we've really offered
it in one way which is
here's some numbers in a method you
follow me do what i just did and then
reproduce it
and so there are some kids who like
doing that and they do well and a lot of
kids who
don't like doing it and don't do well
but when you open up maths and you give
you let kids experience it in different
ways maybe visually with numbers with
words
what happens is kids
there are many more kids who can access
it
so those different
brain wirings you're talking about where
some people are just
more able to do something in a
particular way
that's why we want to that's one of the
reasons we want to open it up
so that there are different ways of
accessing it
and then that's not really a problem
you